true wealth cannot be created working it
can only be created investing elon musk
is completely invested
he has no cash and no houses
because elon knows the money game
he knows the whole thing's a big scheme
there's real estate fun i'm doing and
she's like why are you doing this for
people i said i want to help the little
guy become a big guy
all right believe nation back again long
time friend of the channel the one and
only mr grant cardone welcome back man
how you doing uh always good to be with
you buddy merry christmas early happy
hanukkah um that holiday season time is
here
that makes people more grateful and i
think
it's a good time of the year for people
to reflect on family and accomplishments
and potential appreciate you man well
today i'm i'm super excited because
we're talking investments and i
you know i've consumed your content for
years probably more than most people i
love the entrepreneurship and the sales
and the motivation but my favorite video
of yours that i've seen in the past year
was when you you rolled up on your
office come out of your car uh start
walking into the whiteboard and you're
saying hey if you're a ballplayer if
you're a rapper if you play second base
let me show you how
to invest in real life and then you go
to the white board and you break the
whole thing down like ah mind blown i
love i love this video and
i think a lot of times you don't get
enough credit
because they might see the glitz and the
in the flair and the jets and all that
but not enough credit for how smart you
are with actually creating sophisticated
structures to invest and avoid taxes
yeah well thank you i appreciate you
saying that
you know the the problem with youtube
and and instagram is is if you don't if
i don't do some of that stuff
uh you know it's just hard to get
through man like i'm competing with
you know this week it's omnicron and
and um i think you know you know the
world's crazy dude like it's a loud
noisy crazy world with a lot of problems
in it and and even if you have a great
product and you're you know this like
even if you have a great product great
training great education information you
know the best the best guy or gal
doesn't always win
and typically it's the loudest you know
and it's where in the beginning you got
to be if you don't have any money like
if you don't have a big budget if i
don't have a coca-cola budget i can't
you know i can't compete with the apples
and the googles and the facebooks and
the metaverse and the nft world now that
everything everybody's going to go
digital now right so it's like how do i
get attention and most of the time evan
i don't even know what i'm doing i'm
just trying to do it but that particular
video
we were targeting
uh the artist
uh the athlete the rapper and
and it worked by the way okay like i'll
give you a little i'll give you a little
success story tiffany haddish came to my
house two sundays ago she saw that video
she became a fan because of it
and
i talked to her about this this real
estate fund i'm doing and she's like why
are you doing this for people i said i
want to help the little guy
become a big guy
because what's happening right now in
the investment community is the big guys
just keep getting bigger and bigger
that's obvious to everybody on both
sides like the big the wealthy just keep
getting wealthier and wealthier and it's
because of the asset investment
opportunities they have available to
them
and ball players and rappers don't get
them either rich people do not get
access to the kind of opportunities that
that i'm talking about today it's only
wealthy wealthy institutions and i just
discovered this in the last five years
as i was attempting to do
to
create my own wealth for myself and my
family i started discovering that this
whole thing was on lockdown
that that you got to be super super
super connected to ever get access to an
ipo
uh insider real insider information
about the direction of something or the
economy or
so anyway
you've kind of become the underdog again
when you're going up against goldman
sachs and bank of america and like the
giant financial institutions of the
world and people might look at you say
he's got it all figured out he's like no
no like grant's the underdog trying to
take on these giant corporations again
one thousand percent and and then and
you know the the system set up not to
have this like we we had there's an
accredited fund
what i did was i started building i
started buying real estate years ago as
you know okay i ended up with uh i don't
know about 4 000 apartments that that i
personally own 4 000 apartments the
rents about
you know 2 000 bucks a month one day i
looked up i'm like damn dude i just got
i'm rich like like this is not this
isn't my other business this isn't the
seminar business the event business the
webinar business the book business
this is a business that can go it will
go on and on and on forever without me
this is why so many people are in real
estate because
the the generational real estate can be
created for you know
30 years after i'm dead 60 years after
i'm dead that doesn't i don't need to be
there so we started raising money about
maybe three years ago
and started letting evan carmichael's
uh people that speak on my stages our
business partners our customers invest
with me because people started to hear
about what i was doing
but it was just really high net worth
individuals
200 grand 400 grand 500 grand
and money just poured in dude i couldn't
believe how how fast money came in we
raised 700 million dollars
with no ad budget in three years
that bought two billion dollars worth of
real estate
we've been making distributions every
month to those investors this this year
we we distributed 35 million dollars
in this year
so i've made more distributions that
than most people ever making money okay
and we're sending this back to our
investors well what happened was
uh what the more i started telling
people about that the more 98 of my
audience which is non-accredited
the
98 of america is not accredited they
would not
be able to invest in these funds
and i started kind of feeling bad about
it because i'm like wait a minute the
the very people
i was non-accredited before i was
accredited
everybody's born non-accredited
everybody starts as a little guy right
so i said guys let's i want to start a
non-accredited fund for the everyday
person i want to be able to put a
thousand bucks in a deal
everybody told me do not do it
it's going to be too costly it's too
expensive it's going to bring lawsuits
you're going to have problems little
guy's gonna be up i said hey hey listen
man i want to do the deal i already
thought through all that stuff
do the deal okay so then they started
doing the paperwork to create a fund for
the non-accredited
it took nine months to get it approved
and 350 000 and i probably had 20 people
working on it full-time
now now it's really important for
everybody to hear about this because
this is an education on our financial
system
to get an accredited fund approved it
took me nine minutes and nine grand
in nine minutes boom i had a stamp
saying go raise money
to get non-accredited to help the little
guy out okay everybody listen to this
that if you're watching
to help the little guy out
it took nine months 350 000
and 20 people working on it almost full
time
we just got approved in 50 states and by
the sec federally
to raise money from the little guy so i
started looking in i started looking at
why is it taking so long oh they want to
protect the little guy i'm like okay all
right but why does it take why do what
protect them from what dude i'm buying a
piece of real estate that will always
you can't lose money in these deals
virtually cannot lose money you can lose
money in the stock market bitcoin
ethereum
uh bonds gambling loans all that you can
lose money like
there's almost no way to lose money in
that deal because it's cash flowing when
we buy so what are you guys really up to
and then i started realizing
the sec
was put in place by wall street
it was funded by wall street to regulate
and protect the little guy
but the very people that put them in
place okay they can afford 350 000 to
create their funds they they can afford
30 million
you know and and so and what they did
was they have the exp it's so expensive
to do it nobody does it because a little
guy typically is not going to invest
that kind of money
to let
a little guy
invest a thousand bucks so i i you know
we took it on we did it uh we had uh
we had uh uh 27
000 people registered in the first three
days to put a thousand dollars or more
in that piece of real estate right
behind me i think it's going to be super
successful i think it's going to be
really good for them i know it's going
to be good for them i think it's going
to be good for me also because it
changes the narrative about about grant
cardone
i'm not i'm not just selling a book now
i'm basically somebody's not they're not
really buying anything for me they're
investing with me as a partner
and you know now now we're both on the
same page it's not it's not a consumer a
sale it's not an exchange of a product
for money
you know we're kind of joined at the hip
now well before with your books or
videos or training they still have to go
off and do something
or now they don't have to do anything
you're going to do the work all you got
to do is sign the document i've already
picked the asset and by the way this has
never been done before what i am doing
has never been done in this country at
this level trophy asset
the these are institutional quality
assets
the you've mentioned two groups
that we got deals from
uh this month that we're closing on
they were competing with me for the
deals
like they don't even know what i'm doing
here like i'm nobody to these people
these are trillion dollar companies not
billion dollar companies and not not an
exaggeration these are trillion dollar
companies
that
they have their biggest problem is money
i didn't know all this like this is all
a new discovery for me so i'm all lit up
about this whole thing about this taking
on this giant
because they're not going to call evan
carmichael's family and say hey
blackstone's not going to call you and
say evan we got this great deal it's a
quarter of a billion dollars
and your family can invest
uh 50 grand in it ain't gonna happen
you're never gonna get the call in your
lifetime
they're gonna call their buddies
that sit on other boards
the wealthy you're calling the wealthy
make it more wealth and the little guy
gets left out
so i'm i'm really proud that we're doing
this i'm excited about it the the people
that are investing with me are excited
um so
i appreciate you giving it some
attention
um it reminds me of on undercover
billionaire when you were trying to
raise money in pueblo to get the real
estate deal done and you had to be
careful of like how much you could let
on and like how does this guy know so
much about real estate
you know and and so
the pitch on the whiteboard um
it's great i mean it just
we don't get to see that often the
smarts you know like how the deals are
structured and why it's so important but
and i love that it's starting to come
out more in your content
what are your thoughts on
elon musk and jeff bezos barely paying
taxes and and warren buffett being in a
higher tax bracket than his secretary
like how are these ultra rich guys
basically avoiding paying taxes
because they don't earn income
so look elon does not earn income warren
doesn't earn income and neither does
jeff
so this is the game right we're all
taught get a good job earn and get get a
good you know go to school get take on
debt
get a good job improve yourself at the
job so then you'll get more money but
the more the more earned income you get
the more the more taxes you pay so the
goal is the goal should be for everybody
i've been studying money for 25 years
i've talked about money for a long time
got a lot of haters because i talk about
it so much
but the goal is not to have earned
income
the goal for everybody should be to have
passive income
that you don't earn that you don't trade
time for
so like
in my in my regular business in my you
know if i go speak to a group i traded
time for money
i earned income half of that's going to
go to the tax ban
the half that i end up with i take and i
put in that piece of real estate right
there
with that piece of real estate comes
write-offs deductions
depreciation
and passive income
the goal you see none of us were taught
about wealth we were taught about how to
earn income
and earning income is
you know
those people that earn income uh pay
taxes
so my goal is to get to zero income
earned income and have as much passive
income as possible the only way to
create real wealth is to invest is not
to work hard
this is why warren says i should pay
more taxes it's it's a shame that my
secretary pays more than i do we should
raise taxes on the rich the reason
warren says that is number one to win
fans
number two he it don't matter if you
change the tax code on warren because
he's not gonna pay income anyway he's
not gonna pay income taxes because he
don't have no income
okay he earned 500 million dollars last
year
uh in dividends passive income on his
coca-cola investment
the guy that runs coca-cola made 50
million check this out the ceo of
coca-cola earned 50 million last year
and paid uh 63 percent out in taxes so
he ends up with like 30 million warren
gets paid 500 million dollars the point
of the story is you know you don't want
earned income now in the beginning
you've got to have earned income the
baseball player has to have earned
income
it could be 2 million 5 million 25
million but uncle sam's going to take
most of it
we're not taught how to invest you
cannot create wealth true wealth cannot
be created working it can only be
created investing and investing is
actually the easiest thing somebody can
do so it's a crazy kind of loop
uh we just have not been taught
to use money correctly
instead we save money
now keep this in mind okay
and then i love doing this with you
because it because to me this is my real
purpose is to re-educate people about
money
we're not financially illiterate
we we've been financially
uh programmed
to make mistakes the institutions
and the system that taught us how to use
money benefit
they are the beneficiaries of how we
don't use money okay make money trade
time for money go to the bank and drop
it off and save that only benefits wells
fargo bank of america citibank the whole
list see it goes it goes to community it
goes credit unions and community banks
then it goes wells fargo bank of america
citibank then it goes to goldman jp
morgan and then it goes to the real
players
and it ain't jeff bezos
or elon musk or warren buffett at the
top of the freaking food chain or
companies like blackstone okay and
vanguard
these are these are 10 trillion dollar
companies they run planet earth
they're the richest those two groups
right there are the richest two groups
on planet earth today
they literally have their hands in
everything everything this big they they
control what's on stock on the stock
market who gets a loan who doesn't get a
loan
so when i go buy an asset like that by
the way their biggest problem all these
big giants have problems and their
problems is money they have so much
money
and this money is ain't [ __ ] by the way
this is not new money
new names
old money wait we're very very old
and and they need real estate they have
to consume real estate because it's real
and it produces dividends to their
investors
and the people that hold their paper
you know it's a casino man it's a giant
freaking vegas casino
and in in a casino just like when you
walk into steve wynn's hotel there's
there's blackjack and there's there's
the the pull bars you know 25 cents to
25
the roulette wheels the back rat there's
all these game tables same thing with
the stock market
and and
and and so everybody's gambling and
these handful of companies benefit from
you guys gambling
and then they scare you about the
gambling so they say save your money
plan for a rainy day give your money to
us and we'll manage it because you don't
know what you're doing
and what i'm doing is i'm intercepting
this thing actually barack obama passed
a law called the jobs act in 2012 that
for the first time in history allowed a
guy like me to even raise money
2016 that law was amended to allow me to
raise money from non-accredited
uh the little guy
so when we open this that's 230 million
that's the actual piece of real estate
we're raising money for right now i
bought it with my money
i signed the debt
it's 230 million bucks i sign a loan for
160 and i write a check for 70 million
i do that to give my to give my
followers the audience anybody that
wants to invest with me confidence that
i believe in that deal
if no one invests i own the deal
if people come back and invest we're all
partners
so uh people can invest a thousand bucks
five thousand bucks ten thousand bucks
twenty thousand it's a long term
investment
you are illiquid you can't call me up
three months from now i need my money
back
that's not how this deal works
see wall street
promises you liquidity
notice here's a little thing man stay
liquid you were told that when you were
growing up
you need some cash you need an emergency
account right
keep cash around you need a little cash
and then what happened is once they
convinced everybody to keep cash they
quit paying you anything on it
and so if you look at if you look at
elon musk elon musk is completely
invested
he has no cash and no houses
because elon knows the money game
he knows the whole thing's a big scam
and that's why he said the other day
he's like you guys seem to misunderstand
that i don't pay taxes
because i don't earn income
and the only way for me to pay taxes if
you remember the tweet last week the
only way for me to pay taxes is to sell
my stock you guys decide should i and
then he sold a little bit why because he
needs some money
so the game's on lockdown man and i'm
trying to i'm gonna my my legacy
project will be
to
and i'm courageous enough and crazy
enough to do this i'm gonna take on
these big giants
one of the groups that i mentioned
earlier was trying to buy that deal
and because they're so big they're slow
and i'm small and nimble so i can move
faster and that's how i got that deal
once once we got the deal under contract
they called and said we would like to
give you the 70 million in equity and
we'll keep you in the deal that's how
bad they wanted this asset
and they they didn't want me to go to my
public and raise the money they want me
to come to them for the money
the other thing you seem
to be on a crusade on is re-educating
people on debt that most people think
debt is bad because they're taking on
the wrong debt and you're out here
saying no no no debt is good all the
rich people use debt you have to learn
how to use debt why are people's views
on debt so wrong
well because you know look a a a us
dollar is basically debt there's nothing
to support it or back it up okay
the manufacturing of paper by itself is
debt
cash is debt
okay so
um
you know again we've been programmed
cash is taxed debt is not
so if if we would quit studying our
uncle the millionaire
the millionaire next door which you know
was one of the most inspirational books
i've read in my entire life was that
book
it inspired me to not be a millionaire
i read that book i'm like i ain't gonna
be that guy for sure
okay i got to go buy a used truck i got
to go negotiate buy low sell that's not
how wealthy people operate they do not
worry about whether they don't even buy
cars they're like have a look have a
limo pick me up
so so the thing on debt
i mean the thing on learning is first we
should be studying wealthy people
wealthy people maybe even not people but
institutions
very very few people actually understand
the money game
and it's not the people on cnbc by the
way
those are pundits
reporting the news that know very little
about money
and i and i know that to be true because
they don't have any real wealth
okay they have earned
income so the debt game the debt game
goes like this all right um
apple computer borrowed uh two weeks ago
borrowed uh 90
90 billion dollars
from
japan and they had 140 billion on hand
now why would they borrow 90 billion
when they had it in the bank
because the 90 billion comes with tax
write-offs
and using cash does not
so they get the best of both worlds they
keep their cash on their accounts makes
them look good to their investors
and they borrow money from japan at
almost nothing
for instance we're boring money on that
project right there at 2.8 percent i
think
maybe two point yeah two point eight
three percent
five years
the thing's gonna the thing's gonna earn
five percent the first year
so
i'm earning five percent
on 2.8 money
and that in that that that difference is
how people get create super wealth
debt is all deductible
to infinity by the way
there is no limitation on how much debt
interest i can write off my taxes
so like last year i'll just give you an
insight um i oh today i don't i we have
about four billion dollars worth of real
estate i owe
um
2.2 billion dollars
in debt
i want more debt i don't want less
uh if the world goes to hell by the way
i get helped out
because now now it's just too big to to
to just you know they they want to help
so we weren't taught this i didn't even
know this until 2008 i discovered this
in 2008 i owed 50 million dollars to the
banks and the banks pay up pay up how am
i why you calling me i've never even
been late because we know you have money
i had money in an account cash
see when you have cash people will sue
you and banks will come get your assets
when you have debt they leave you alone
can't you can't get uh blood from
attorney or whatever that saying is okay
so let me just tell you what i paid in
in interest last year you can write off
up to 750 000 worth of interest on a
home
and then you can't write it off anymore
i wrote off 88 million dollars in
interest last year no limitation that
number could be 800 million 8 billion 80
billion it's all tax deductible
so we need to reprogram how we think
about debt okay and and also how we
think about cash
you can also write off the depreciation
right i mean right at the beginning well
this building right here good good point
like this building you know
if i save cash
it goes down in value but i don't get to
write that off
everybody knows cash is going down in
value i think it's lost 90 percent of
its value since warren buffett was was
uh born
90 of his value 90 pennies out of every
dollar
that building right there we will write
all i'll own it for 20 days in december
we'll close december 10th
and i'm gonna write off on that deal
probably 28 million dollars in the month
of december
my jet i just bought a brand new plane
54 million dollar plane i wrote off the
entire 54 million dollars in the month
of december
took one business trip
that's why coca-cola buys planes
that's why pfizer has helicopters
so that's why we all need to figure out
okay hey what's really going on here and
and for all you guys out there you're on
the come up right you're trying to
figure out okay i'm making 30 40 000
bucks a year okay first thing you got to
do is get your income up second thing
you do once you get your income up do
not spend earned income above what you
need invest all of it
so let's say let's pretend somebody
could live on 50 000 bucks a year
and they go from 50 to 80. don't spend
the 30
live on the 50
make more money
take the 30 and and put it in a real
asset that has depreciation
and debt
you go next year you go from 50 to 100
you make more money take the whole 50
don't change your standard of living
don't go buy watches and
okay don't go don't go improve the
quality of your life improve the quality
of your investments take the entire 50
all of it okay i dare it i dare you guys
to have the courage to do this
at the end of every year i get rid of
all my extra cash and i put it into an
asset
i walk into january first every year
with zero money just like i did in
puebla
so so when when i did undercover a
billionaire they they said when i was
flying into pueblo they said what's the
first thing you're gonna do i said first
thing i'm gonna do is go to the bank and
drop off this hundred dollars
and they're like well why are you going
to get rid of the 100 you're going to
need i'm like i'm never going to spend
that hundred dollars
they didn't show this in the show but i
never spent that hundred
never touched it
because i always act like i have nothing
and in most cases i don't because i take
my cash which we know is going down in
value
and i put it into a building
i get rid of it i don't want to touch it
nobody's calling me for cash because
everybody knows i've made it public i
don't have any cash you want to sue me
you're going to have to break that damn
building down
like it's going it's you got to pull
teeth to get money for me because all of
it's in a building or a partnership
where it's protected and that's what
those rich guys are doing to prevent
their uh their themselves and their
families and their future estates from
being taxed
so someone investing cardone capital and
we'll link that up in the description
below guys you can go check that out and
say they get 10k in distributions
from you for the year yeah how is that
taxed let's say we can walk through some
numbers
10k in additional income from earned
income versus 10k cardone capital
distributions what's my difference in
paying taxes on it so so if you earn ten
thousand dollars you're going to pay in
the state of new york you're going to
pay
uh 6 300 bucks in taxes let's say you're
making 100 grand a year
you're going to be taxed as earned
income is at the highest rate
on on passive income
that number should be
uh below 20
and if you're an accredited investor and
can take advantage of the depreciation
which most people can by the way you're
not going to pay any taxes on that ten
thousand dollars
so a five percent let's say
let's say you put 200 grand in and
it paid five percent return
it's passive income you did not work on
the project passive means you didn't
touch that project you didn't buy it
look for it hunt it down
manage it
a lot of people are investing in real
estate they think they're getting
passive income you're actually going to
get taxed later as earned income
okay when you're buying a building
yourself and managing it that's earned
income not passive income
so we have third party management so i
don't i never touch those buildings i
buy them
and then we have a third party that
manages them and all the investors get
passed through passive income
which should be
um
treated by your accountant as
with a k i'll send a k1 to you
at the end of the year that says hey we
paid you 10 000 but you're allowed 30
000 in write-offs i'm just giving you an
example it's not an exact example
so that can actually offset against your
other income as well so that's why so
many people use real estate they use
real estate so many people use real
estate number one because it's real
protects against inflation it cash flows
but the other reason is because it
starts it becomes a a tax haven
without having to go to the caymans yeah
i think i think that's the biggest thing
people are missing because they think of
passive income just as i don't have to
work and i get money coming in which it
is but the tremendous tax savings on top
of it yeah you can even carry forward
the future years is crazy yeah and you
know there's a lot of a lot of
misunderstanding about this there's a
lot of e-commerce guys that talk about i
get passive income i'm like no bro you
don't
if you ran an ad that's not passive
income
passive income is basically by
definition it's uh it's real estate
royalty income
copyright like it's something you did
one time and then you sold it to
somebody and then they pay you nfts are
going to be by the way a passive income
provider
if it works out if it doesn't blow up
all over the place but it it's if i sell
a piece of art today and they trade it
later and i get paid that's passive
income
but me having to go out do a piece of
art sell the piece of part that's active
income the second third fourth fifth
time it would sell that would be passive
and it should be treated as passive
what do you think is more likely
grant cardone gets his own show on cnbc
grant cardone runs for
senate or governor
or grant cardone launches his nft line
um the most likely
probably one two three order them order
them yeah uh order order well i do have
an interest in politics i i'll tell you
i'll tell you a little behind the scene
thing
my goal
my ultimate goal with this is to put i
want 20 million people to invest money
with me
so we have an email database of about 3
million people right now 13 million
people online
um
we're definitely i'm definitely getting
known in the world right now okay so i'm
starting to break through
and um
so the goal the internal goal is i want
20 million people to invest 10 000 with
me
that'll be
200 billion dollars in cash
that's a war chest now
200 billion dollars in cash will buy one
trillion dollars worth of real estate
see the beautiful thing about you know
the ability to crowdfund from the
regular everyday guy
is when you send me a check
and then i start sending you money back
me and you together we're we're we're
buddy you're you're my guy
i'm your guy we're we're we're now in a
business together
somebody says something bad about me
you're gonna be like hey knock it off
man that guy pays me in my family every
month
now imagine if i wait and do this for 10
years and i have 20 million people that
i've been paying for the last 10 years
every month
and let's say i want to run for some
office you know
and you're in that booth saying you know
grant man i you know i don't really i
don't really like his political abuse
but god damn it he's been paying me
every month
so so we're going senate or congress and
which party
yeah well i'll go with the party that i
can win with
okay if i ever did that right but but i
mean the whole political thing i would
just do it because i'm a disrupter i
like a fight
you know i like i've been i've been the
little the underdog bullied ever since i
was in high school
i was looking at some high school books
the other day somebody showed him tell
me i'm like yeah bruh
mike mike ormandal that beat the armada
or whatever his name was it beat me up
i'm like yeah but i bet he's seen what
i'm doing now you know i have this
little chip on my shoulder right so
i like those fights
and i also like seeing problems and
trying to do something about it
so if you could wave your magic grant
cardone wand and and change one
law what would it be
well right now
uh i would change man there'd be a lot
of my change uh one the first one i
would be i would do is
i would i would change the 12 year
12 years of school
and and and and reward the schools that
can get kids out in eight years
it's just too long
man but nobody wants to be in school for
12 years come on man it's terrible
all right so that's one thing the other
thing is i would i would uh you know
i would definitely not this whole
mandating thing's crazy it's insane
i i would i would say look if you don't
want to get vaccinated we're going to
send your two shots to the countries
that need it because there's countries
that can't get the vaccines
about 35 of the american public doesn't
want to get the shot so good man
donate pfizer donate my two shots
to africa
they need them you guys say you can't
get them
quit trying to shove them shove them in
my shoulder send them to people that
want them
last question just on cardone capital
we've talked about going into debt
under which scenarios should people who
are considering getting on your deal go
into debt to do so no they should not
nobody should borrow money to to invest
in that deal
okay you know what what money should be
using you should borrow money to improve
yourself you should borrow money for
your own business but i would never
borrow money for an investment
now that being said if you have equity
in your home you got four or five
hundred thousand dollars worth of equity
in your home earning zero
you got two or three hundred thousand
sitting in an ira or 401k or you got 40
000 you're self-directed like you're you
have a self-directed ira or a 401k
i'm sure you have something sitting over
there but you're as a self-employed
person if you have a retirement account
or you left your company years ago and
you now have your retirement account
that's self-directed i would use that
money i would borrow against my house
i would borrow against the equity in my
house and invest in that deal
but i wouldn't go i wouldn't go bored
ten thousand dollars on a credit card
uh to invest in that deal so someone
hasn't i would i would borrow 10 000 on
my credit card to go to an event that
taught me how
like i would always tell people yeah
dude load up on your credit card if it
makes you better i would i would i would
borrow money for marketing
but i wouldn't borrow money to invest
with grant cardone capital
so someone has 10k equity in their home
right now yeah they pulled it out to
invest in cardone capital what am i
paying an interest on my home and what's
my
how does that does that math work out
yeah yeah yeah it would work out
it would 100 work out
and and uh so i would borrow i would
grab ten thousand i i think i think that
that person i
you know would be in a better position
to find ten thousand dollars some other
place like just go to your mom and say
hey i'll give you the ten thousand
dollars equity in my house against ten
thousand dollars because there's cash
everywhere right now
there there's about 12 trillion dollars
sitting in cash accounts today
there's about 12 trillion sitting in
equity in homes it's all dead money
and that's why you see these big groups
going out and buying homes right now
the housing market anybody that thinks
there's gonna be a housing crash you
guys are wrong there's no chance of a
housing crash in this country there's a
shortage of housing today
there's there's a there's a there's a uh
oversupply of investors buying houses
that have never existed in america in
our entire 200 years or however long
we've been around here okay we have
investors buying homes now
that are replacing the end user
buying a house there's a shortage of
supply there's there's massive inflation
hitting hitting most of the housing
stock materials concrete glass we're
going to get inflation interest rates
will stay at zero otherwise the entire
u.s government will have to go bankrupt
we'll we're never going to see high
interest rates in this country again
just because we have too much debt we
can't it's just monopoly now
and this will be the safest asset class
i believe for the next
20 years we're in a super cycle where at
the beginnings of it
it will be the place that people should
have their money uh and so like
how does somebody make sense of the ten
thousand i think to every ten thousand
ends up being twenty grand in five years
maybe thirty thousand
better scenario
is i send you back to 10 000 in five
years
and you still you're still an owner with
me in the property because i'm going to
refinance the property
with new debt
send you back your 10 grand non-taxable
event
rich people sell stuff wealthy people
never sell anything
buy borrow diet
huh buy borrow die yeah exactly so like
like if warren wanted money right now
what worm will never pay taxes okay like
the old man he's the smartest salesman
in the world
he would just go borrow against his
berkshire like
he'd be like i want to borrow
10 million again he i mean how could he
need he doesn't need money like ever
right
he's just going to go buy another
company
you know you know that he his 70 of all
his investments are in four stocks
he is
he is not he does not do what he tells
everybody else to do which is hey you
guys need to diversify your investments
most of his money's in four different
stocks elon's got three stocks jeff
bezos one stock steve jobs had two
i love it well
the main is grant cardone the website is
cardone capital we'll link that up down
the description below go check it out
grant as always appreciate you the time
the education and looking forward to
more financial content coming up from
you man good the shirt looks great on
you bro and and uh the hoodie looks
great on you evan i appreciate you so
much man i gotta tell you yeah i gotta
tell you man when we did uh what was the
thing we did with evan
we did a challenge and you were on it
bro you were freaking
like
that was amazing
amazing we got to figure out how to do
that i told you that then now we just
got to figure out how to do it so
i i mean let me know happy to help man
okay i appreciate you brother appreciate
everything you're doing man all right
much love thank you grant thank you
brother see you soon if you want to see
the one-on-one i did recently with grant
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i'll tell
everybody right now i didn't hit the
target spoiler you got kovitz yeah they
are testing me every week the first week
i test positive i'm calling home every
night
on my new phone to my wife crying like a
little baby